can you share five lessons that will
help someone be a better filmmaker right
now I think five lessons that'll make
you a better filmmaker right now is
first trust your actors actors are
always gonna come in there to try to
elevate the material to try to create
better work for you
so always trust your actors number two
don't get so trapped on what your vision
is that you're so focused on it you
can't listen to other ideas or other
people because that'll limit what you
can get
third is don't give up you know what I
mean if things aren't exactly going your
way that doesn't mean that there isn't
something right around the corner or
something that you can do to kind of get
to that quicker
I think another tip is to read a lot of
scripts I think reading scripts and then
watching the films that were actually
made off of the scripts you'll learn so
much about how the story was actually
executed it's one thing to see a movie
and be like oh this is how I would have
done there this is how I they should
have done it but when you read the
actual material that it was based on the
blueprint itself and then see oh I was
interesting the way that that director
executed the scene or the blocking in
that scene was was different than the
way I would have blocked that scene but
that was interesting another bit of
advice that I would give is edit edit
projects as much as you can because the
more as a director you're onset thinking
as an editor the faster you'll be more
concise you'll be and the more able to
get what you need
onset is because you've spent that time
in the Edit Bay seeing what works
seeing how cuts takes and work to get
cut together and elements kind of don't
you don't need and things that you do
need really helps with that so I think
cutting projects cutting stuff on your
own is really essential and I remember
one of the things I did in film school
was
I would take a like let's say a scene
from you know whatever your favorite
movies are whether it's Lawrence of
Arabia or The Godfather or whatever you
take those phones and you take a scene
you drop it on a timeline and you just
find all the cuts for that scene and
your notice and you look at it and yet
in whatever editing program you're using
like oh they cut from that to that to
that and it really is a invaluable way
to see how a scene plays out how cuts
can get either shorter or faster how the
director and the editor creates suspense
or tension by the way that the cuts are
laid out in the scene so that was a
really invaluable learning lessons by
looking at other projects and seeing how
they were cut it's excellent yeah I like
that yeah it's really good yeah do you
remember the the films used to watch
again Oh like some of the ones that
really stuck out were you stuck out to
me yeah trying to think that's okay but
it's hard to it's hard for me to choose
five films or just a list of film that
had a lot of you know that kind of left
an impression on me as a filmmaker I
think more than anything it's you know
the directors themselves and their body
of work that I look back on and kind of
get inspiration from like looking at
Kubrick looking at how he was able to
kind of tap into different genres like
horror the war films and all those
different genres that he touched on how
he would uniquely shoot a scene it was
always interesting that would always
give me inspiration I'm like okay you
know I was those those different way to
shoot this scene so I'm out try to think
of other directors or other filmmakers
and see how at their work they might
have approached a similar scene and try
to be like oh that's that's different I
never would have thought of that but
that'll kind of inspire me as a
filmmaker I mean Kubrick Spielberg
Kurosawa
Christopher Nolan those are the type of
filmmakers where their work is so unique
and such a strong voice that anytime I
need inspiration and want to just kind
of draw back into that creative well I
can just look at any of their films and
find something unique or different that
will help like motivate me and inspire
me
and speaking of chess we talked about it
earlier in the interview cooper used to
play chess for money right no he was
yeah Kubrick was he approached the
filmmaking process like a chess game in
a way right every problem that came at
him was you know another move on on the
board and he would always try to
anticipate two steps ahead other things
that could happen and it's chess is not
just an analogy for filmmaking it's
really an analogy for life where you
know if you can become a good chess
player then you can you know put your
mind in that mindset you can become a
better filmmaker and then hopefully a
better person because you can kind of
look at life in it from that perspective
okay he had a very unique way of looking
at the contrarian way yeah in a lot of
ways we know interviews with him it was
very interesting guy yeah very
fascinating figure
you